good morning and welcome to this
licensing act 2003 hearing uh this is
the subcommittee to hear um an
application for a new premises license
in respect of uh burnt house vineyard
builders and road little finbr stone
market
the
subcommittee and the hearing will be
take the form of a fairly informal
hearing procedure
the there'll be some administration to
go through uh first of all um then the
the hearing itself will will take the
form of the licensing officer will
present um a brief outline of the report
of the application to the subcommittee
the
the um
applicant will then be asked to
uh
representation towards their
application and there may be questions
from the the members of the subcommittee
and and with permission of the the chair
of the subcommittee other parties to
this uh hearing can ask also us
questions
there will also be an opportunity for
those who've made representations to
make uh their representations verbally
and again questions may be be asked in
respect of those representations there
will then be a short summing up
procedure uh everyone will have a a
quick final say with the um the
applicant having the final word uh the
subcommittee will then go into a private
session to make their decision and we'll
come back as quickly as possible to uh
announce that decision so i'm going to
move on to uh
the election of chairman that there is
no election as as councillor kathy
guthrie is the the chair of the full
licensing and regulatory committee so
we'll take this subcommittee this
morning over to you council guthrie
thank you very much indeed good morning
i wonder if everybody can keep their
microphones on mute please it's going to
be quite difficult
for um people to do that i understand
but anyway welcome to the virtual
meeting of the licensing subcommittee um
my name's cathy guthrie and i am taking
the meeting today i'd like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to youtube and capable
of repeated viewing
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential and exempt items
if you make representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consented to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
so virtual meeting etiquette please
ensure your microphones are muted when
you're not speaking
and in this instance to keep your um
cameras off it's just to make sure that
we get good connections and you can put
them on when you are speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt meeting
you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by myself so
please wait your turn
so do we have apologies for absence
please
run receive chair
thank you declarations of interest by
councillors are there any declarations
uh chairman i probably should declare
that i am i personally know
one of the objectors
mrs true love
thank you i don't think that is
i think the lawyer
could advise me on that
nigel if you'd just like to comment
thank you it's just supposed to be
provided you are able to confirm that it
will have no influence on your decision
making of the subcommittee
no thank you chairman
excellent
thank you very much so i'll do the
formal introductions again my name is
kathy guthrie we have councillor penny
otton
who's one of the members and councillor
dave muller
we have the officers in attendance nigel
de liu who you've just met our legal
advisor
kay sanders our licensing officer kay do
you want to make yourself known
good morning thank you chair
we'll see you in a minute um is
catherine greene with us or not no no no
right okay and the governance officer
who you've already heard as well as
karen sayer
good morning everyone
good morning to you karen thank you
um can i ask the applicants uh mr mr
scarf to put their camera on and
introduce themselves please
uh so i'm katherine scarf and i'm
representing uh mr and mrs scott today
ah right okay
because that was my next question
is anybody um going to be represented by
so can you um confirm receipt of the
procedure the reports copies and late
late uh papers
yes
you did thank you
and that included a letter from mrs true
love that i've got here
yeah just get that copy you did
thank you excellent
so if you'd like to switch your screen
off for the moment please you get used
to it it's either your mute or switch
your screen off it it sort of goes along
those lines
so
the next people that we have
um
we have mr kenneth mudd would you like
to introduce yourself who you'd like to
make some views to us at the meeting
hello my name's kenneth mudd um i live
in little finborough in the row of
houses which are adjacent to the
vineyard
um and my concern hang on we'll allow
you to talk in a minute it's just to
introduce yourself to say hello okay
thank you
thank you thank you mr mud
and um we've heard
mrs crickmore by um phone and is mr
smith with you as well for the
yes i am
right
and mrs crickmore you're there aren't
you
yes yes i'm here one of the residents as
well i am still trying to get in on
microsoft i don't know if it will let me
but it's asking for a code is anybody
away
no
um i think that's going to sort of delay
matters but it should be on the email
that was set up it should have been on
the email that was sent to you
um no that's the link there was a code
never mind well we'll just do it by
phone and i'll i'll give up trying yeah
okay don't worry we will hear you and
we've got your paper um copy of of
comment here as well
um so do any of the parties wish to
withdraw the application or their
representation
no no
no
right thank you
so this is my question to the licensing
officer now have there been any requests
for the parties for permission to call
witnesses
no chair
and have the parties indicated they wish
to present documentary or other material
other than what we've received already
nothing other than what we've received
if i could just note that the um
additional material submitted by mrs
true love um she did mention
another property um the occupier from
that house has not submitted an
objection
thank you very much indeed
so
i need to go around everybody and ask
you timing so i'll come to the
applicants please miss um well it'll be
catherine scarf thank you how long do
you think it would take
for you to present your case please
uh hopefully maximum four minutes oh
four minutes right
and mr mud how long do you think you
might be to present your case i
originally said eight minutes but i
think it's probably near a five
five minutes thank you i don't think
we're going to hold you up for one
minute it's just to get a feel of the
length of our meeting and finally um
mrs um crick moore and mr smith how long
will it take for you to present your
comments we both wanted to say a little
bit of something but i don't think
either obviously we'll take any more
than about five minutes
but probably about
ten
i beg your pardon
we probably only want two or three
minutes each we're both going to say
something individually
right
okay i think that's satisfactory nigel
do you agree
it's good yeah
it's your discretion
yes
it seems it seems appropriate for the
matter before us so may i now ask
um the licensing officer to present your
report
and summarize the matter under
consideration please
thank you chair
this hearing is to determine an
application made for grant of a new
premise license made under section 17 of
the licensing act 2003 by stuart and
jill scarf at burnt house vineyard
builders road little fimbra stone market
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 7th of
february 2022
and a copy of this is attached to this
report as appendix a
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation the notices
advertising the application have been on
display at the premise and published in
the east anglian daily times on the 8th
of february 2022 edition
full details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained within the
application form attaches appendix a the
operating schedule steps proposed by the
applicant to promote the four license
objectives are attached as appendix b
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
representations which have not been
withdrawn
the subcommittee will be aware that its
consideration is confirmed um confined
to the promotion of the four licensing
objectives and the need or commercial
demand for licensed premises are not
considerations for the licensing
authority when discharging its licensing
functions
the license authority must carry out its
functions under the act with a view to
promoting the four licensing objectives
which are the prevention of crime and
disorder public safety the prevention of
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm
the subcommittee will also be aware of
human rights act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 for the applicant
and articles 8 and one of protocol one
for those raising representations when
determining applications for the grant
of the new license
the licensing authority has received no
representations from the responsible
authorities
further considerations and conditions
have been agreed by the applicant after
mediation with environmental protection
these are attached as appendix d
there have been three representations
received made by other persons which
include local residents businesses and
residents associations this is attached
as appendix e
the subcommittee must having regard to
the representations made take such of
the steps if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing
objectives to grant the license subject
to conditions which are consistent with
the operating schedule accompanying the
application
modified to such an extent as the
authority considers appropriate for
promotion of the objectives
all licenses are subject to all
mandatory conditions which must be
included in the license
to exclude from the scope of the license
any licensable activities which the
application relates to refuse to specify
a person in their license as a premise
supervisor
or to reject the application
and if i can just note for clarification
live and recorded music have been
applied for but under the license and
act deregulation a license is not
required to stage a performance of live
music or the playing of recorded music
if it takes place between
8am and 2300 hours and it takes place at
an alcohol unlicensed premise and an
audience of no more than 500 people that
concludes my summary thank you claire
thank you kay i will now ask um
the applicant and the other person's
present if they have any questions
of the officer of what they've heard or
any questions for clarity really here so
um catherine scarf do you have any
questions for the officer
no questions
and mr kenneth mudd any questions yes
i'm just asking about the um the fact
that there's no license required for the
music
at all
is that that's what i understood
with someone just to say yes the hours
that have been applied for
do in actual fact come under the um
license and act deregulation
okay thank you very much
and mr smith
um
for an event of up to 500 people
um for music we don't need a license at
all or there's no
permissions needed for that event to
take place
if the premise is subject or has a
license in place for on sales of alcohol
and it's between the hours of eight in
the morning and 2300 hours no more than
500 people under deregulation
um a license is not required
okay
what happens is the license is issued
for off sale and not on sale what what
is the difference between the two it
would need to be licensed
so if it's off sale where they can sell
wine
like a shop does yes then presumably
they wouldn't have the they wouldn't be
able to do amplified music but if it's
am i right in understanding that if it's
on sales it's selling
alcohol by the glass
and then they would be able to do music
is that the difference with that
that that's correct if if it's not one
if it wasn't on on the license and they
only had off sales
they wouldn't be able to do the
deregulation if they had off sales and
wanted regulated entertainment i.e music
then they would have to include it on
their licence application
that's difficult getting your head
around it but that's the answer to your
questions i think yes
would they be able to apply for a
one-off
license for music with off sales or
would it have to be and apply
for off sales with music because it
doesn't come under the deregulation
if something didn't come under
deregulation and they just had off sales
and they wanted a one-off event they
could apply for a temporary event notice
okay lovely i understand now
it is confusing but it's worthwhile
making it clear thank you for your
question
so can i
can i ask the um subcommittee counselor
otton do you have any further
questioning because i know that was
something you were
interested in
can you put your mic on please
and then we haven't done that now
um yes i mean
the other question i think we need
clarifying
is the difference between
what a planning application
requires or does not require or what
limits there will be
between that and the license
the mission and i think it would be
useful
if
could just explain that for ourselves
and the members of the public please
thank you for your question nigel if you
could come back with that one please
yes um we have basically two separate
regimes
the council is a local planning
authority and it is also the local
licensing authority and when it acts as
one or the other
it only concentrates and only deals with
the application of that legislation
so there will be a certain amount of
criteria when um giving planning
permission it's more of an amenity
related issues
where the licensing deals solely with
the four licensing objectives
now there is
potential for
permissions to conflict with each other
for example
a license may be granted
for
say 24 hours a day
because that application does not
um overly impinge on the licensing
objectives but there may be planning
reasons why a planning permission will
only grant
opening hours for say 12 hours a day
now where you have that
instance
it is up to the the owner of the
premises
to comply
with both sets so therefore it's the one
that has the lesser hours that they need
to comply with because if they extend
over those hours although they're not
committing any breaches of the licensing
legislation they are breaching
the the planning legislation and it will
be for the uh the local authority is the
planning enforcement authority to take
action on that so although you may have
a 24-hour
license if you do not have the the
requisite planning um consent
to actually operate during those hours
you have to stick with with the with
with the lesser time limit um and vice
versa you know
you could have planning for for 24 hours
but for whatever reasons under the
licensing objectives the subcommittee's
decided that
that's too long you would have to
restrict yourselves to to what the the
licensing committee has has imposed
i hope that makes that clear
thank you very much
oh that's very clear and very helpful um
councilman muller do you have any
questions for the officer or uh no
questions for the officer thank you
chair
right
thank you very much indeed so we now
move on to um catherine scarf to present
your case if you would please
okay
so i am attending the hearing as the
designated personal license holder for
burnt house vineyard and representing
the application made by jill and stuart
scarf of scarf farms
as a designated premises supervisor i
have level two award for personal
licence holders
fenn's farm is a fourth generation
family farm
after many years of planning we
diversified the farm in 2017 and planted
a vineyard the vineyard is 22 acres and
is one of the largest in suffolk our
grapes supply both our own production
and another brand
in 2020 we decided to further diversify
the farm and have our own grapes
vinified in order for us to have our own
brand of wine which is the first vintage
is set to be released in spring 2022.
to allow us to sell our wine we are
currently constructing our cellar door
this will allow us to sell directly to
our customers however also allow us to
encourage customers both near and far
away to visit our vineyard and learn
about an exciting new industry our
vineyard and celador will be creating a
number of skilled jobs
we are applying for our premises license
to enable us to sell alcohol and soft
beverages and from time to time have the
ability to host events
after discussing with representatives
from environmental health we concluded
that a number of conditions should be
applied to ensure that we protect our
neighbours and support the licensing
objectives
we would like to be able to offer
seasonal tastings wine and cheese
pairings food with wine flights and
outdoor events including wine tours and
tastings and walking wine tours
events with over 51 attend attendees
will be limited to 20 per annum for
example harvest celebrations and those
mentioned in the application for the
license
wedding events will also be limited to
20 per annum i will ensure that close
residents are always kept informed of
the programme of events
myself or an appointed member of staff
in charge will always be on site if an
event has been organized
we can confirm that myself catherine
scarf will be the point of contact with
regards to any noise and my contact
telephone number is available for the
village community
further conditions that have been
proposed ensuring that we measure noise
levels if and when an event takes place
therefore we have further created
documents of working practices that will
be in place of the premises licenses
granted which i believe was circulated
and the dispersal policy
and that will be in place is
will be put in place to ensure that the
customers leave quietly with
consideration of our neighbours we'll
have signs displayed for this purpose
and all staff will be trained to ensure
that customers respect our neighbours
and will be asked to leave quietly
a noise management plan has also been
created to outline how during events we
will manage noise to ensure that there
is no disturbance to our neighbours and
during events customers will be held in
the event space who are waiting for a
taxi so there's no undue noise in the
car park
we've also created an aid verification
policy to ensure that all staff are
trained in the supply and sale of
alcohol
our staff will be trained in checking
ids and applying the challenge 25 policy
all staff will be trained in level one
award in responsible alcohol retailing
and we will not operate outside of our
planning conditions
and fire risk assessment food safety
regulation assessments and health and
safety risk assessments will be
completed when the building is near
completion
and there were further comments made
from a representative so we wanted to
answer some of those questions
um that were asked about the conditions
that were proposed with environmental
health so please note that the property
that is mentioned belongs to my brother
who also works for the business james
has confirmed in writing to the
licensing team that he does not want his
property referenced or to be including
the application and that he believes his
house is closest in proximity
we can deliver the program of events to
those who wish to receive this by email
or letter if they're unable to have
access to the internet or walk to the
vineyard
um and music will be measured to those
stated in proposed condition section
seven and monitored by our noise
management plan
and there is an agreed lighting plan
approved with mid-suffolk planning to
ensure that we do not disturb or have a
permanent effect on the wildlife and our
neighbours
we have also a dispersal policy that has
been circulated to ensure that noise
from customers leaving is monitored and
does not cause disturbance
thank you
sorry i'm smiling because you looked as
though you were having to hold to the to
the minute but you know it was just
flexible to know
um how long people might take
so first of all if i ask the other
person's present um just if they have
any um
questions again
so i will ask
um mr mud do you have any questions
um i did have one question please yes um
catherine said there would be no
disturbance to the neighbours
sounds travels quite a long way
how will you ensure please that
the sound is not audible to the
neighboring properties
so one of the conditions uh
section 7 is that we will be monitoring
noise levels so
the noise should be
not exceeds
la-90 by more than 5 db in any 15-minute
period so as
mentioned in our noise management plan
we will be purchasing a handheld monitor
and um be monitoring the noise and
keeping record of that to ensure that um
noise isn't isn't a made a disturbance
to the neighbors
how loud will that be
in my garden
is the question really that i'm asking
so i i believe
that the la-90 is just background noise
um
so it's it's a level that is is
considered not to be a nuisance um
according to environmental health
and five decibels is almost four times
as loud is that correct
i'm afraid i don't know the specifics on
on the decibels um how loud that would
be
okay thank you very much
um mr smith do you have any questions
uh yes i think i have a couple here um
katherine mentioned that there's gonna
be
wine
sold uh soft drinks
probably hot beverages is it going to
include
spirits beer is that on the agenda
or will they not be included at all
is it just going to be wine
and soft drinks
so our primary business is to um
offer our wine
um
however it it might be that customers
don't want to drink wine
so some customers might come as a couple
one likes wine one doesn't but they
still want to have the experience of
seeing the vineyard and enjoying the
space therefore we would like to offer
other beverages so as such as beer
so you will be selling spirits and beer
yes possibly yes
possibly
so yes i think isn't it
possible so
yes
but not on the spirits
so no spirits
my intention is not to sell spirits
can we just have an interjection here
for a minute if you could just tell for
a minute um with kay um would you just
like to clear that the license would
allow any variety of alcohol could you
just confirm that yes it would yes thank
you
so um do you have any further questions
um yes it's regarding noise um
it's uh a limited
15-minute period so is it going to be
noisy will the noise levels rise for 15
minutes and then somebody will say we're
going to have to turn it down and it
goes down for 10 minutes and then it
goes up again for 15 minutes and then
someone says well we've got to turn it
down again are we going to get this
noise coming and going or
or i'm wondering how this is going to be
monitored
i know you've said you've got handheld
monitors but
it it's this is a very gray area there's
nothing um
almost in stone i would like to have a
bit more reassurance as to look we
really won't hear very much at all
but i fear we may be forever having our
when we have our windows open in summer
on a summer's evening at half 11 we get
quite a lot of noise interference
intrusion
so half 11 um we've not applied for the
music to go on that late so
um
the licence been applied for is for for
licensed music to finish at 11 and
there's a extra 30 minutes on our
opening times just to allow for drink up
so if someone's bought a
drink they can drink up
and with regards to the 15 minute period
our intention is to keep that a very um
uh solid noise we don't intend on having
something loud and then dropping it back
down that's that's not the intention at
all it is to keep a a steady noise level
which using the noise management plan we
would be constantly constantly
monitoring that at different different
points in the boundaries
okay
is it is it just a suggestion is it
possible to have
um
[Music]
apparatus that measures the noise level
so when it hits that noise that turns
the whole thing off
is that a possibility
or is it just going to be somebody
listening and pointing a machine at
something and saying oh we've got to
turn it down
um
well i think your noise management plan
covers that doesn't it that you would
make
you know
so
so it would be managed manually it
wouldn't have an automatic cut off um
but with the noise management plan as we
are
um
uh you know taking that that reading a
regular time and recording that as well
um so that would be for environmental
health to to to see
um
you know that's when we would be
adjusting the noise levels but again
just to reassure our intention is not to
you know fluctuate that noise for 10
minutes and then drop it is to keep a
level noise level
i i think mr smith you've had a sort of
a good inquiry to the noise level of
what's proposed uh nigel would you agree
with me on that that we've sort of
explored that
quite fully do you think
yes chair i mean
there's there's no one here from um
environmental protection because they
haven't made any concerns themselves um
there's no one here with with the
technical uh knowledge on these um and i
know they have they are quite complex
all i would say is is that these are
conditions that our environmental
protection team are are satisfied with
um and feel that
would mitigate uh sufficiently to avoid
any impact on the the licensing
objectives
thank you and i i didn't mean to cut you
short mr smith but you know as nigel's
just explained we you know there's a
limit to sort of the the answers that we
can get at the moment and what's
proposed do you have any other questions
um for say um mrs crickmore or mr smith
do you have any other questions please
well i would just like to point out
if um
if people present could look at page 41
that's a plot that's been sent out with
the notice of hearing it's the sort of
aerial photograph
of the area under discussion
and if you look at the bottom right hand
corner where it says builderston road
the car park for the venue
is
right next to the road at that point
and the other side of where it says
builderston road you can see a hedge
line that is actually part of our
property that is our garden which is
your question
what is your question please
the noise level from the car park is
going to be
much louder for
us in particular because the car park is
immediately opposite where our garden is
so this is quick
you have a question you'll have an
opportunity to say all this in a few
moments but this point of proceedings
it's just questions for for miss scarf
well it's it's a comment really i mean
any increase in the noise level is is is
going to be a lot more than what it
currently is okay you haven't
tried to control it
more you'll have your opportunity to
expand on that in a few moments but as i
said this is the point of proceedings
for questions if you have no more
questions then we can move on to that
part of the proceedings
thank you so i'll now ask the offer of
the members um counselor ottoman do you
have any questions at all
could i just clarify
on the
um events you have 20 events and 20
outdoor events
um
i'm assuming some of those would be
within a marquee
and i'd like clarification of whether
that's classified
as an indoor or outdoor event
and the other thing is you've obviously
got parking for 50 cars but if you had a
large event like a wedding
obviously that would include
considerable number of people needing to
park their cars where would they
park their cars
so um i would classify anything in a
marquee is outside
uh not inside and um with regards to the
parking
so
we do
so the farm entrance is actually
opposite and we have further parking
that is available
um opposite the vineyard site
okay
thank you
and if i may just jump in um councillor
muller just going on from that point
what sort of numbers um well i suppose i
should ask have you got any proposals
for wedding events at the moment and
what sort of numbers are you looking for
we have no current proposals for for the
weddings
thank you
councilman sorry i just jumped in on the
back of thank councillor
that's fine thing just just one question
which i sort of picked up from from the
papers um it seems that the premise is
still under construction can you just
confirm when the premises will be
completed please um mrs scar
yep so uh we're we're hoping to be um
completed uh by the end of july
thank you very much uh no further
questions thank you chair
thank you very much indeed
should i just comment on what the
additional
just a minute please can i just continue
with it with the case and you'll be able
to make your comments any minute now i
promise you
so if you would just let me continue the
way um matters are going please
um so um we move on to all of you people
who are listening in and wish to make
representation
and um in the fashion i've got it here i
will ask mr mud now to make his
presentation please
thank you chair
i was surprised a bit to hear that
there's been an application for the
license not for the sale of alcohol but
because of the outside events but i now
understand that the two are intimately
connected
the planning or authority approved the
building on application reference dc
stroke two zero stroke zero three seven
five six
as office accommodation and visitor
facilities
in connection with the existing vineyard
and stated that it shall only be used as
ancillary to the main agricultural
vineyard use of the site and for no
other purpose
the approved operating times were 8 am
to 6 pm
mondays to fridays
9 a.m to 6 p.m on saturdays
and 10 a.m to 5 p.m on sundays
the local authority placed restrictions
on changes of use to enable it to retain
control over the development in the
interests of residential and rural
immunity as this development was
permitted for very specific purposes
the application for licensing with its
wide hours
appears to be a departure from what was
approved
it says that the vineyard will host a
variety of events from time to time such
as weddings and private events
and unless the definition of scope of
these events
is very limited they would appear to
fall outside the permitted use of the
facility
so
leaving that aside whether or not it's
possible or not if a license is granted
i don't think that the proposed control
measures
are success are satisfactory to ensure
that the quality of life of the
neighboring properties is preserved
and it will not be wholly in the
interests of residential and rural
amenity
little finbra is a tiny village and i'm
keen that we and all our neighbouring
village residents and businesses
remain considerate and harmonious
and that we all take into account the
needs and desires of others and the
scarf family themselves have said this
in their events dispersal policy which
says
we encourage the building and
maintaining of close relationships with
our neighbours local residents and other
business operators
the premises operate a good neighbor
policy and run and manage the business
with a view to this policy
so i hope that if a license is granted
conditions can be written agreed and
applied in a way that will satisfy
everyone
i've noted a few issues here that i
think
need to be clarified or subject to
changes in the proposed conditions
the excess noise and i understand now
that that's not real that's
inextricably joined with alcohol sales
we have to be able to allow our gardens
as residents at any time of the year
and
the
number of events that have been proposed
that's 14 big events and an unlimited
number of smaller events
is greater than what i would expect from
the statement from time to time
the
proposed controls as they're written
would allow that those events could be
collected together so you could have
the events with more than 51 people all
collected together in the summer months
so that there are
uh there's at least one event every
weekend throughout the summer months
when other people want to be using their
gardens
and there's no assurance that an event
with fewer than 50 people will be any
quieter than a larger event because the
sound level is not dependent on how many
people are listening to it
and we know that sounds travels a long
way
when the local fate was held on the
meadow opposite the vineyard
i could clearly hear that in my garden
and
it occurred during the event and when
people were arriving and leaving
but that was a community event and it
only took place for two evenings and one
day in the year
the notification for to local residents
that's in the conditions
uh says that it's
going to be on a website on our notice
board regularly that puts the onus on
the people locally to go and check
unless the events are notified several
months in advance
and it's nice to have the ability to
find out when the events
will be taken will be taking place
but there shouldn't be any disturbance
that we need to be informed of anyway
so there should be no need to notify us
but it's very nice that they're planning
to do that
and also if there's no disturbance there
won't be any needs for any complaints
but if there is necessary
then if it is the phone necessary to
make a complaint
then there needs to be an assurance that
that complaint will with will be dealt
with quickly
and there'll be procedures put in place
to stop the same cause occurring in the
future
so and even if the noise itself from the
event is kept very quiet and doesn't
disturb the neighbors there's still the
issue of large increases in the amount
of traffic
up to 50 cars assuming there's no
overflow parking could be leaving the
site at any one time so that's what at
least half an hour's consistent traffic
they'll be accelerating as they leave
the vineyard
and that will be as they go past the
neighboring
properties that will result in lots of
additional noise and especially late at
night headlights perpetually lighting up
people's gardens and front windows
that will it will also potentially
affect the rural area of the the rural
nature of the area
with increased pressures on nocturnal
wildlife that's trying to cross a road
that's previously been very quiet and
suddenly has got very very large amounts
of traffic on it
talking about noise level measurements
the method proposed doesn't ensure that
as consistent level
is acceptable to the neighboring
residents will be maintained the type of
noise
affects its tendency to result in
annoyance
so if there's a thudding beat of of some
music it's much more obtrusive than an
even toned noise
so the absolute intensity is measured by
a decibel meter is not the only
determinant
and
the judge who who judges what is uh
acceptable noise appears to be entirely
with the applicants and without
consulting with the neighbors
the effect of the light pollution on the
character the area in the wildlife has
to be avoided
i know the path flights have been
approved by the planning authority but i
can't find any description of what the
other external lighting would be for any
outside events
so if the license application and
propose
sorry if the license application and
proposed conditions are to provide
flexibility just so that the scarves are
not limited in what they can and cannot
do
at any particular time but that they
plan far fewer events than actually
the maximum permitted
i think the condition should be written
to reflect what actually is proposed to
be taking place
so thank you committee and chair for
your
attention and taking all these points
into consideration
thank you very much mr murdo i was
making certain um amount of notes there
as you were speaking i would just ask
nigel um
it's something that people have
difficulty with is understanding the
planning permissions and the licensing
permissions um now you mentioned
um the um the approval
for the planning
and
i think nigel if you can just explain
that one more time as to how
not one trumps the other but how and
what we are dealing with here today
please it would be helpful
yes chair it's really a matter of um
they do trump each other um if if one is
more restricted than the other
as i said earlier you are making the
decision on the impact that the
application has on the licensing
objectives and that's all you are
considering
if the premises doesn't actually have
planning permission
to operate as a licensed premises that
doesn't prevent you issuing the license
but it does prevent the owner of that
property
operating under that license until they
have the relevant planning consent so
the obligation is always on the the
owner or the occupy of the premises to
comply with both sets
of of legislation um so if you know they
may be able to comply with the licensing
but if they can't comply with the
planning as well they leave themselves
open to enforcement action in under that
legislation
i hope that
yeah thank you nigel that's very helpful
being chairman of planning and chair of
licensing i've had to um battle with
this for many years but i just hope that
puts that in a bit of a more perspective
for everybody to understand
um and that we focus specifically on the
licensing for objectives today um so um
i'll ask my um colleagues um cancer
rotten do you have any questions at all
i know we are supposed to be
obviously concentrating on the
alcohol license
but i would it would be useful to know
what we have in the paperwork the
planning application
with
limited times is there a
another planning
application imminent then
on
the very improve the enlarged proposals
i i don't think we can even discuss that
cancer rotten we've got to look at
what's before us
and if that happens at a later date as a
result of whatever our result is today
then so be it am i right there nigel
yeah and that's certainly not a question
mr mud can answer because i'm sure no
exactly
that kind of information it just seemed
slightly caught before the horse a bit
you know
sorry but we've been doing this for long
enough and it really is a very difficult
one but um it's not for mr mud to answer
as nigel says no of course not
absolutely not
okay so do you have a question for mr
mud at all that was my um oh no beg your
pardon chairman no that might
thank you
um and um
i'll ask councillor muller do you have
um a question at all for mr murder
uh no questions mr mud thank you chair
and can i ask um the applicant catherine
if if she would like to have any
questions at all please
no questions thank you
i'm right
um and i think that covers that side of
thing thank you mr mud thank you for
your presentation and as i said i made
uh quite a few notes as you spoke thank
you thank you so i will now move on
uh to mr smith and mrs crickmore and you
can take i know this mr
you were going to pass some comment
earlier so if you want to start
and then um you know tell us your side
of things and then perhaps mr smith
follow afterwards would that be
appropriate for you
yes that would be great thank you very
much
then
thank you okay
i'd like just to begin by pointing out
that this is not a licensed renewal as
already has been said it is a first
application for a new license
the building itself has not even been
fully constructed yet and when the
planning permission was granted it was
for use as
ancillary to the main agricultural use
of the vineyard site
it is also located on the vet on the
edge of a very rural community and again
if you look at page 41 of the
documents sent out with the notice of
hearing
the
car park
is in the very tiny little corner
opposite where it says builderston road
in white and the hedging on the other
side is actually our property so our
property in particular is within about
20 yards of the car park and as
catherine mentioned with overflow
parking
the
access road to fenn farm
opposite the site
has a set-aside grass area that goes to
the bottom of our garden which they have
previously used as overflow car parking
when the village fate has been held
and on that occasion our property was
turned into virtually a roundabout with
a one-way system
for the overflow car park which i would
not want
on
any circumstances
so if i move on i am very strongly
opposed to the licensing application as
it is so far removed from the original
plan for a tasting building visitor
center and office accommodation that the
planning department agreed to
um item seven and eight of the planning
restriction placed on the development
when the planning was granted
the additional football and vehicular
traffic this license will bring to the
area will cause loss of immunity to our
property and nuisance prejudicial to
health for residents in the area and by
that there will be increased traffic
causing danger to horse riders walkers
and other road users in an area where
there is no public footpath and only
just enough room for two cars to park
personally as i have already mentioned
our property is one of the closest to
the venue it's just been cut off on the
aerial photograph
it is a listed building and as such we
have no double glazing to alleviate
noise pollution which means we will be
disproportionately affected
increased noise will disturb grazing for
my horse in his field
i've previously needed to sedate him for
safety at times of excessive noise
because it scares him
personal use of our gardens will be
disrupted for all residents in the
area um
again if you look at the picture of the
field you will see the hedging of our
boundary is directly opposite the car
park and the visitor center
which means that we will be directly in
line of any anti-social behaviour that
may occur at closing time
when cars are leaving the site late at
night with doyle's banging and vehicles
speeding away that's within 20 yards of
our property of our garden
um
specific restrictions were made by the
planning department regarding this site
limiting operating hours between eight
and six monday to friday nine till six
saturdays ten till five on sundays the
site itself was approved for office
accommodation visitor facilities in
connection with the vineyard only and
for no other purpose
in conclusion i sincerely request that
you
either refuse this license or allow it
to go forward for off sales only
i'm unhappy for on sales because the on
sales come with the addition of live
amplified music
and amplified recorded music
which is going to cause a great deal of
concern for local residents
um it will be impossible for residents
to live a happy life with 20 indoor
events and 20 outdoor events
amplified live or recorded music
annually these events could cover almost
every weekend throughout the year
with
marquees there is absolutely no sound
proofing at all
if the music finishes at 11 and then
people are leaving at 11 30.
if there were off license sales at the
vineyard
for
vineyard visits there could be ticketing
ticketed events for tours which
include wine tasting so they would not
necessarily need to be a license for on
sales
there could just be a license for off
sales
that would be the only way i could see
that this would move forward
those are my views thank you very much
for giving me the time
is that okay has everybody heard that
no there's something else
so you're mutual
yeah sorry i'm muted sorry about that um
can i just ask a question looking at the
location
of the proposed car park
on the builderston road
which is printed and then it says fenn's
farm so i'm on the right area aren't i
and then there's a
there's sort of
like um
a grade area which isn't is that the um
unattended piece of land
it's that there's a grey road you you've
got the the the little blue dot where it
says send farm and if you go to the
right of that
yeah builders to the road again yes sort
of a dark area which is a shadow of the
hedge
and the green area to the right of that
is my garden yeah but what's that what's
the the the area that's not cultivated
there's a big
sort of grayish looking area is is that
a menage or something or is that owned
by the
there's a wood on one side of the road
on the top half of the picture then the
road and then underneath the where it
says builders road which is upside down
underneath that is our
garden garden there's a wood on the
other side of the road which oh right no
i've sorry i've turned to the right and
headed off further
towards where there's um yes i i
understand now i've got my orientation i
think the great area that you're looking
at is where the new house has been built
ah right thank you for that that helps
me that helps me that's located me and
delocated me and relocated me so i know
where you are now yeah
if you go down towards the far points
yeah to the right hand side of where
that grey blob is yeah and where where
it where is it
yeah i've got it where is the field for
your horse then
behind where it says builderston road
that's my grass field underneath oh i
see i've got it yeah
if bilderson road is upside down you'll
see that there's a corner of
that that's my that's part of our
property
and right
field
actually this aerial photograph doesn't
show the car park but the car park is
right opposite where it says road i do
the car park is right in that time yeah
all right i've got sorry i've got my
orientation now yes i understand i
understand thank you for that clarity
um and now thank you for that now then
um
sorry i've rather jumped in there um
counselor often do you have any
questions um
uh
at all for
uh no
no um councillor muller do you have any
questions for mr crickmore
just one for clarification if i may
please chair uh mrs crickmore you said
that um if the overflow car park is used
by going into fen farm that your prop is
basically in the middle of a roundabout
so
would it be that the exit from there
will be the other side of your property
please
that that's what has happened in the
past um if you see the blue blob on the
aerial photograph where it's yes then
farm
um
the the village green is to the left
which is where they had the fate once a
year
and on the right there's a small sort of
triangular shape before you get to our
hedge in our field cars were all parked
along there and the scarfs have actually
got a set aside track that goes down the
back of our field
and the overflow car parking they would
come in off the road and park on that
little part of grass then they would
drive down the setter side
which would go all the way behind our
property and join up with jack flame
which isn't on this aerial photograph
jockey's lane sorry jockey's lane
um and that would then make our property
into a roundabout so they'd come past
the front of the house
to go on to the overflow car park then
they'd go behind the back of the house
when they leave along the set aside to
join jockeys lane which is a road used
at the public path and then rejoin the
builderston road again
now when it was for the village fate and
it was only once a year you don't mind
you get over it but if you're planning
on using
yes i was going to say i i've got the
orientation of it yeah yeah so that that
sort of answers your question councillor
muller is that correct yeah that's fine
yeah thank you mr crickmore that's fine
thank you chair
yeah thank you um
now um let's see where we are um kay do
you have any questions at all
um just just one point um that mrs [ __ ]
moore said
if they were to just have off sales and
um sell tickets for tasting
unfortunately that would constitute an
on sale so they would still need to be
licensed for that because there's any
sale taking place
it needs to be licensed
if they bought tickets for a vineyard
tour they wouldn't be able to give free
drink away
no because they'd have to buy a ticket
to get their free drinks so therefore it
still constitutes a sale since yeah
so um if i ask um catherine scarf do you
have any questions um for mrs quick more
at all
no questions thank you
thank you
um
so mr smith would you like to add
something um as you said you wish to
speak
yes please uh good morning everybody my
name is paul smith and i live at america
cottage on bilderston road
um
i would like to add
some additional points i think probably
one or two crossover from other people's
points already
the original application
considered light
for a visitor center an office
accommodation closing at six in the
evening
using the building for other activities
after dark would require additional
lighting
this would change the nature of the area
and potentially affect local wildlife
this was not considered when the
planning authority approved the lighting
plan
because it was
generally during daylight hours
um
there is currently parking provision i
know we've covered this a little bit for
50 cars for events with more than 50
people it is possible that the parking
may be insufficient and overflow parking
would need to be in place
this would further increase the traffic
noise and disturbance i've never just
learned that the
overflow parking will be potentially
next to my property on the end of our
garden
um
is this going to be tarmac is this going
to be a hard standing because at the
moment it's
a field set aside field it's grass
and in our field we have
uh and in the hedgerows we have
various types of wildlife there which um
include owls we've got
uh
hairs in the field we've got badges that
now come in
um
these would be adversely affected i'm
not sure about bats that maybe were
there as well but i haven't had a
census on the wildlife this is just
knowing now that we're learning now that
we can have an overflow car park at the
end of the is not
really what i want um
during the day we experience
occasional disturbance from passing
agricultural commercial
and domestic traffic
much of this is very necessary for the
functioning of business in the area but
it remains a predominantly rural area
if an event venue is allowed to run
music will be heard constantly at night
with the increase in the volume of
traffic this will
this will change the character of the
area for the worse
i feel not only for myself but for other
residents in the area
the original planning approval was for
the building to have wine tastings
and tours of the vineyard
the new proposals to turn the building
into the equivalent
i feel of a public house
with multiple choices choices of alcohol
being served until 11 o'clock at night
rather than
vineyard wines being sold until 6.
uh the events dispersal policy
as does the signage for proof of age and
requesting people to leave the premises
quietly
that signage confirms that benny will be
run
as a pub in my view which again is in
direct conflict to the granted planning
permission for a visitor center
and for these reasons i'm against the
application thank you very much chair
for your time
thank you very much indeed um nigel can
i once again
bring you in please because
there's a couple of things here it's
people are very concerned but it's a lot
of it is on the planning issue
and i quite understand and my view would
be that the set-aside agricultural
arable whatever you call it land would
need planning permission for change of
use to a car park
and my view would also be that the
issues that people are raising quite
understandably that again it would be a
planning issue and an enforcement issue
for change of use etc could you just
confirm my views in your views as well
bearing in mind your licensing and all
we are dealing with unfortunately is the
licensing aspect but i want to give
comfort to the people that are raising
these issues
that
we can and have in the past
given licensing
but if there's something that stops it
there's something would stop it and
would have to be resolved we are dealing
with the licensing would you just
confirm that again please that that's
correct yeah as i said before if the the
property does not have the benefit of
the appropriate planning permission and
the correct planning use
it cannot operate under that legislation
it may have a a license under the 2003
act the licensing act but if it doesn't
comply with the town and country
planning act of 1990 um
then then it cannot operate there won't
be licensing enforcement but there will
be planning enforcement
um and as i said before you're just
concerned with the four licensing
objectives
of this application
yeah thank you and i really wanted you
to reiterate that to give comfort to the
people that are listening we haven't had
our debate yet but um you know i think
people need to understand that there are
two issues here and we have to look at
both but being chair of planning i know
applications have to go in for change of
use and
modification and enforcement etc and i
can see dave nodding his head
that's also on planning as well so
whilst i hear your your points of view
there
they will be taken into account but not
in
a discussion that we may have regarding
the licensing activities
so i will just ask um penny do you have
any further questions for mr smith
uh councillor often sorry
uh
no thank you chairman
and councillor muller
uh no no questions thank you mr smith
thank you chair
and thank you mr smith and uh mrs
quickmore we have made copious notes and
when we go to debate we will certainly
take take all those points forward
so um very much does you're welcome um
does um catherine have any questions for
mr smith um as the separate
uh contributor to this do you have any
further questions or for him
no thank you no thank you
right
so we've been around everybody to ask
all the questions
um
so i think we now go to
um
the applicant to come up with the final
statements that correct nigel
yes chair unless the licensing officer
has anything to to add at this point um
it's then for the the application oh
right okay well i'm sorry i briefly
asked ken i didn't didn't sort of
specify that's okay do you have any
further things to add
no chair i just asked question to add
and so now i'll come back to you um
catherine scarf to just give your final
closing statement as the applicant
always has the opportunity to do that so
if you'd like to add anything we'd be
pleased to hear it thank you
so thank you very much for um all being
here today and and to being able to
listen to everyone's you know concerns
and for our application as well
um
everything that's kind of been
been agreed with environmental health is
to ensure that we protect our neighbours
with public noise and nuisance and
ensuring that we um
uh look at the licensing objectives um
and
further from that and from the comments
that were received initially um we
we drew up noise management plans
dispersal
policies and and others which were
circulated to ensure that we do enforce
these and make sure that we do protect
and the concerns of our neighbours as
well thank you very much
thank you
so now we move on to exclusion of the
public so i think everybody's had
sufficient time
and on the basis that the subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public it is resolved that
under section 100a brackets iv of the
local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for item six on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the act
on the grand set out in the regulation
14 brackets 2 of the licensing act to
2003
brackets hearings
regulations 2005.
may i have a member to propose the
motion please
happy to propose chair thank you and a
seconder please
can that chairman
thank you very much indeed what will
happen now is we will pause the live
stream and the members of the
subcommittee and the legal officer only
will go to a different room to
fulfill their debate and come out with a
conclusion
so there will be a delay now for those
of you waiting thank you very much
indeed thank you
foreign
well thank you very much all for your
patience in waiting i will ask um nigel
to give us the result of our
deliberations thank you nigel over to
you
thank you chair and and thank you
everybody for waiting as you can imagine
the the members have
deliberated quite carefully on this
matter
and the decision they've reached is
actually a majority decision of two
votes to one
but the decision they have come to
is that they are generally satisfied
that the proposed conditions agreed with
environmental protection services
sufficiently mitigate the concerns
relating to the noise light and traffic
concerns raised by the uh the local
residents um however they're granting
the application subject to
changes to some of the conditions and
the addition of a further condition
the conditions to be amended are
condition to
which will include a provision that
notifications will also be carried out
by
letters to the immediate neighbors of
the property
condition 4
will be amended
insofar as that the the total number
of um events per calendar month will be
three rather than four and the reasoning
that the the members came to this
decision
was that it was generally expected that
these types of events will be held
during the summer months
and which will kind of make it possible
or even likely that every weekend will
hold an event because it
kind of considered that they would tend
to be on on the saturdays or the sundays
um so reducing it to three per month
would at least
make sure that there is at least one
weekend um and every month the summer
where no event will be taking place
the other slight amendment to that
condition
is that the licensable activities in
outdoor areas shall cease by 2300
rather than 23.30
and condition five should also be mended
in
in a similar way in that all events of
those natures shall terminate by 2300
and the additional condition was one
that wasn't actually um discussed during
the the committee but was was raised
during the the conversation that the
members were having and and that is for
um there to be um
a
prohibition of all fireworks um at any
event at the premises so therefore no
fireworks will be allowed which you know
are quite common these days for wedding
events but it was felt that given the
environment and the nature of the area
it was important to include that
condition
any party present to this
subcommittee who's who made
representations is agreed by the
decision or the imposition of any of the
conditions
can appeal against the the decision or
any of the conditions
and that appeal should be made in right
into the magistrates court within 21
days of receiving written notice of the
the subcommittee's decision i'll now
hand back to the the chair council
guthrie
well thank you very much indeed um that
was very um
a fulsome response to what we had
debated
um and before i closed the meeting i
would just remind everybody that the
planning issues do need to be directed
through the planning um
group in mid suffolk district council so
those are though they all need to be
addressed um and we can't do that in
licensing but i felt that
i ought to mention it
as much of it was discussed during our
meeting so i'll thank everybody for
their attendance and um now close the
meeting thank you very much indeed thank
you chair